hey guys how's it going welcome to ig
likes i'm justine and this week we're
going to talk about
this first video a bunch of people said
this to me because i was complaining
about a fedex box that i've recently
received and it was completely
just
demolished jenna
i was gonna show you this fedex video
no
no toss i may not talk about that she's
definitely looking she's laughing she
thinks it's funny oh watch this you
could have just set those there
yeah couldn't you have oh making more of
a mess i guarantee you this woman has
been long yeah no she's she's gone
peace this next video i'm a huge
zayfrank fan he's been one of my
internet inspiration idols for as long
as i can even remember he was pretty
much the person who created vlogging so
when i saw this video pop up in my feed
i was so excited because one of my
favorite animals are owls some owls bob
their heads up and down in order to
maximize their depth perception try it
right now focus on an object and bob
your head up and down
that's right keep bobbing your head so
i've got a bunch of tech stuff for you i
recently purchased the
bit flex which is the same as the fitbit
one which is a little clip that tracks
your steps tracks your sleep i actually
do prefer the one because i like to be
able to clip it on but the flex is kind
of cool because they do have different
kind of bands and different colors the
sad part is it doesn't have a number so
i don't know how many steps i've had hmm
this past couple of weeks people have
been going crazy about the chromecast
it's this little tiny hdmi converter
that you plug into any of your hdtvs and
will allow you to control your
television through any device tablet
phone even ios thank you google for not
leaving out us iphone users they're
currently on back order and i'm kind of
excited because it's a 35 solution to be
able to watch all of this content that
is on all of your devices on your
television a lot of the stuff is now
built into your tv but comparing this
with the apple tv you're gonna save
yourself a couple hundred bucks so next
up i've been traveling so much and
there's so many books that i've wanted
to read and i've just not wanted to
carry the books with me or actually have
to read them so having somebody read a
book to you is by far the most genius
idea ever a lot of my friends told me to
check out audible so audible actually
gave me an audible.com ijustine that
will give you guys one free book and i
just downloaded my free book so we can
do kind of like a book of the month club
this is amazing you guys don't even have
to read the book it's read to you so
it's awesome because i just went online
downloaded my free book from audible.com
ijustine and i downloaded my first book
which is by josh sundquist just don't
fall i actually did read the book but
it's awesome because he actually
narrates
the book just don't fall by josh
sundquist physical therapist glues two
stickers to my back to the lower part of
my back so you guys don't know josh
definitely check out his channel
definitely check out this book that you
can get here on audible.com so let me
know what book you guys decide to
josh sunglasses download don't fall if
you haven't there's a link below to get
your free book and let me know what you
guys think i'm pretty freaking excited i
forgot what else i was going to show you
guys
oh i almost fell okay sorry i always
forget about beauty stuff because i
just don't know but i use a lot of stuff
so recently i just started using the
sally hershberger the glam wave is
texture spray and even though my hair
isn't curly it gives it some sort of a
texture a little bit of body so if i
move it all around like this
it looks good right
this is josie moran i just run into
sephora and like see things and i'm like
this looks cool
it has a little smell to it it's a
liquid blush so i just kind of do this
do that
do that and then set it with powder so
it's really magical
okay now what is happening with this
hair i totally screwed it up
thank you guys so much for watching this
episode of ij likes be sure to tweet me
and instagram me and find me and all of
the other places that you can
find me
they gonna find me they gonna find me
too
oh sweetheart also um
somebody gave me this at comic con so
thank you so much it's so cute i didn't
even get to meet you but it is a octopus
cat it's called
tentacle kitty
i don't know it's pretty sweet though
that's all i've got for you guys today
don't forget to subscribe i'll see you
later peace
out